bienvenue vous écoutez envergure est ici
on parle de tous les jeunes basketteurs
promis à un bel avenir que ce soit en
france en europe et aux états unis notre
credo on regarde beaucoup de matches
interview et on évalue ses prospects sur
notre site envergure point ces eaux on a
recensé plusieurs milliers de joueurs
avec évaluation écrite mais ici à
l'audio on va plutôt confrontés nos
opinions et donc on papote vous écoute
et de préférence avec notre site ouvert
à côté bon épisode à vous si c'est bien
abonnez-vous si c'est très bien commenté
et si c'est génial partager
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue à tous pour ce
nouvel épisode dans leur club ici plus
petits qui parle et je suis en compagnie
dont l'incroyable
[Musique]
etienne-marcel terre du chanteur comment
tu vois bien content de te retrouver sur
les ondes et oui hyper excitées de
lancer ce nouveau projet on va vers gurs
aujourd'hui on se retrouve du coup pour
papoter de josh christopher c'est un mec
on va voir qui a déjà été drafté mais
dont on n'a pas suffisamment parlé sur
nous l'an dernier et on est la pompe
session de rattrapage avant de se lancer
dans le grand bain de la nba ce que tu
es chaud et ses clients très très chaud
à une job
alors on est parti alors déjà on va
commencer par nos classiques jeux
christopher ceux qui bossent christopher
c'est un arrière
physiquement c'est un cas qui mesure qui
mesurait en fait au moment où toutes les
stars qui a été court ce que m 95 et aux
combes aïn el beïda retrouvailles il a
été mesuré à un mètre entre 1 m 92 avec
5 août
2006 d'envergure donc une belle
envergure et il faut qu'on en parle 98
kg c'est son poids et c'est quand même
un poids remarquable pour un bond en
arrière
et pour ses qualités physiques
ouais les mecs et quasiment deux fois
plus épais que moi donc j'irai pas
cherché la bagarre avec lui
effectivement tu l'as dit arrières
arrières viabilité arrière bien tant
qu'e mais dans le général qualités
athlétiques etc c'est quoi le ressenti
que tu as sur ce joueur c'est un athlète
quoi sonatel qui va très vite il peut
avaler le terrain avec une grosse
vitesse et puis de montrer très très
haut
ce qui donne un
joueur qui peut être un moment
spectaculaire a autant au dunk en
contre-attaqué chrome os un coup contre
et puis sur votre phase de jeu ça c'est
intéressant et puisqu'on parle de son
physique en fait juste pour donner une
idée n est pas ce que ça veut dire à peu
près voilà entre m 92 1 mètre 95 98 kg
là les mensurations 20,6 me trompe pas
actuel de l'ue d'or tu le veux l'arrière
bodybuildé de de l'oklahoma même si la
bce n'aime voir mais visuellement ça
donne pas la même chose et puis il est
plus lourd que bradley bis avec la à peu
près la même taille situe à
[Musique]
et puis dernière petite comparaison
il ya les mêmes qu il ya à peu près les
mêmes morceaux
à
sa dépêche trois débats et lui d'orthe
si je me trompe pas socialisme mas
feuilleton la honte tu connais ton sujet
alors effectivement si tu si james
harden c'est parce que on en reparlera
plus tard le joueur était tellement fan
de james trader d'ailleurs un besoin est
et il a porté son numéro 13 qui était
retiré les modèles autorisation indienne
ce que je connais tu vois un peu james
et il a eu cette autorisation des
joueurs qui qui est très fan de notre de
notre ancien m veepee le barbu et
d'ailleurs
son jeu est assez similaire pour parler
de son jeu si on danesin aujourd'hui
tourner cette émission c'est parce qu'on
a vu déjà déjà quelques évolutions
quelques surprises par rapport au jeu de
john christopher entre la pré-saison la
summer league est ce qu'on est
l'habitude de voir au parcours inférieur
donc lycée puis n'diaye voilà ça il
arrivait à la fac avec une réputation de
ce coureur et puis on a découvert
effectivement ce coureur
et puis qui prenaient pas mal de shoots
il adore soutter
est bonne en reparlera sûrement temps à
parler souvent les dernières avec
twitter s'il prenait des shoots un petit
peu déséquilibré son
geste peut-être n'aura temps d'en parler
d'expliquer un peu et c'est que son
équilibre au niveau des jambes n'étaient
pas parfaits et puis
ce qu'on a vu déjà en summer league en
présence était qu'il y avait quand même
une amélioration déjà
c'est rapide pour ça et et puis il était
réputé savoir défendre quand il m'a dit
tout à l'heure mais il ne faudrait pas
trop trop ou mal moi je moi je veux
plutôt de défendre plutôt cette position
qu'il défend des mâles défendez pas pas
du tout mais malin et façon mad histoire
comme secret invasion
basse on a souvent cette cette
discussion en fait pourquoi est ce qu'on
disait alors il n'y a vait manu et moi
qui est ton qui tuera séduire charge à
ce que cette affaire en fait ils y vont
c'est qu'il a les outils pour défendre
donc on va expliquer comment parle de
titre à défendre il a toutes les
qualités athlétiques il à la mobilité
latéral il est très puissant en bas du
corps donc tout ce qui fait qu'on on
peut avoir fort défenseur mais il se
bougeait pas à quoi ils essaient passé
tout le monde il était très focus sur le
ballon à l'opposé c'était n'importe quoi
mais dans une équipe dans un contexte
collectif aussi il faut le rappeler ça
défend d'être très peu à côté
on enseigne sur le conte en scène sur la
situation à l'usma states et sa arizona
bachelot propos m je te propose on parle
de ce qu'il a connu avant ce qui va
connaître maintenant pour qu'un peu les
gens qui nous suivent la piste à une
projection est ce qu'il va voir le même
relais ce qui va avoir avoir les mêmes
attentes et est ce que ce qu'il a montré
à l'université sur les capacités
individuelles qualités athlétiques là
pour ce transfert combat en nba ouais
donc il y arriver à arizona state
comment s p s'inquiète toile donc un
gros prospects et tout de suite qu'on a
vu ses qualités physique athlétique et
c'est par ses qualités de au scoring
c'est un gars qui produit beaucoup au
niveau du score acquis qu'ils essayent
tout le temps à tout le temps tout le
temps d'attaquer le panier il a fini
hors jeu je pense qu'il a fini 4e ce
corps auront le times d'aidé freshmen
d'arizona state pour situer le bonhomme
dans l'équipe et y jouer donc il était
arrière en reste cool je pense que tu as
avec rossi et un résultat esthétique
d'arrivée il était à côté de
deux seniors arrière qui aiment eux
aussi énormément le ballon c'est
martin et burns marty qui continue sa
carrière
qui veut à kansas mais dégager permis
dans la conférence l'éleveur d'ipad et
donc il a joué à côté d'eux il a été
décalé
au poste je te 3 voilà ils étaient trois
et donc en fait c'est pour le niveau de
l'alchimie des kicks ass est jamais très
bien passé mais ils ont souffert
qu'ovide
je pense que ça l'acclimatation a été
difficile et martine c'est un honneur
qui est lui au centre y qu'on peut le
dire
un supporter le mot c'est insupportable
c'est pas si on fait des fortes amélie
dédié aux centristes
qui regroupe qui recouvre beaucoup de
choses ils adorent monopolisé chevalier
et ils produisaient beaucoup de
créations et quand il est pas là c'est
le russe qui prend le relais
ouais je suis d'accord peut-être quand
il y a alors pour le coup même si pas ma
conférence comme j'aime bien raté ma vie
j'ai regardé le plus de matches
possibles n'diaye dont beaucoup horizon
d'ascète et on attendait
le début excusez moi pour les volets
enfonce année chaque et décidé de
détruire ma maison attendons quand il
est arrivé à la tête très vite en fait
il a été première option offensive de
façon assez surprenante notamment lors
du tournoi d'invitation
ah bah oui voilà il ya eut pris beaucoup
de responsabilités beaucoup de tirs
comme tu dis qu aux ide des blessures
quand il revient réuni martin s'était
installé comme lui le patron offensif du
coup de jeune christopher ccd calé en
deuxième troisième option
pour revenir chaud les laitières qui
prenaient effectivement que moi je
refais est détestable parce que cgt
jamais en ellipse était tout le temps le
le pied en avant pour essayer de
chercher un contact c'était le corps
qu'ils étaient articulés alors que
pourtant on était puissant au bas du
corps donc j'avais très très très très
peur ce prospect on rappelle que comme
tu disais prospects très attendu il
était top 20 il espionne deuxième
arrière du pays voilà un mec avait quand
même une grosse cote qui était surveillé
par les programmes
2002 à himeji or depuis 2010 est donc il
était en année sophomore de liste et
qu'il était hier très très très convoité
et chez envergure on avait souvent ce
cette opposition on avait ce qui mettait
déjà christopher très haut et ceux qui
mettaient cameron thomass très haut et
souvent c'était un peu à compatible à
mai soit déjà ce que je dois faire assez
haut et cameron thomas sainte premier
tour sur le contraire moi je suis du
stim cameroun thomass et pourtant le
juge christopher là en summer league
c'est défensivement qui m'a vraiment
impressionné
plus qu offensivement même si j'aimerais
bien pour l'un d'eux sur ce point assez
sous côté salah passe
toi tu en penses quoi de jeu christopher
à l' écoute il était complètement
commande est déchargé de sa
arizona state parce qu'il a comme c'est
dit avec les deux mineurs vêtus de la
vue avec ses deux meneurs ses deux
arrières qui joue à ses côtés
il était toute la création été phagocyté
par ces deux jours donc lui il a il été
chargé de créer pour lui quand il avait
le ballon et créer uniquement pour lui
après ils pouvaient lâcher très vite la
balle en contre attaque parce qu'il est
bien à contre-attaquer mais au niveau du
jeu j'ai pas grand chose et c'est vrai
que ce qu'on a vu en summer league et de
match donc là on enregistre et les
jeudis
et le premier match de présaison est
passé et dans le quatrième quart temps
il a joué donc en quête d'un quatrième
quart temps et c'est lui qui remontait
la belle sytématiquement
surprenante de voir ça mais ça veut dire
que les rogations de quelque chose sinon
que tu ferais pas monter la balle sont
haendel est valable
il est valable
pour je ne sais pas ce qu'ils vont sous
la pression peut être mais pour se créer
des shoots il est vraiment la page voilà
il est capable ou par contre les crabes
lui capable de se créer des petits
espaces de
ma passion fans de james harden donc on
a vu quelques step back déjà moi je
trouve fluide un changement demain
d'ailleurs on ma gauche jeu léger mais
j'aimais vraiment beaucoup vu au niveau
de la finition près du panier du coup il
arrive bien à varier le rythme comme il
est puissant au contact il n'a pas peur
cotisé il y va et en nba ou pour ce
qu'ils valaient allait aussi
intéressant à ce point de de remonter la
balle est ce que tu penses que josh
christopher il va pouvoir jouer cette
année on ne rappelle qu'il est en
compagnie de kevin porter junior je
crois qu'il a beaucoup d'espoir de diane
greene facal ya beaucoup d'espoir eric
gordon est encore là
donc peut-être dj augustine évidemment
est encore là aussi peut-être compliqué
et quel combattant de jaws christophe
fois qu'est ce qu'on va surveiller sur
cette première année et par la suite sa
carrière nba dans son contrat rookie
en fait je pense que comme tout le monde
moi je le voyais à sortir du banc et
être à un scoreur
additionnel quoi je vois qui vient du
banc
parce que parce que c'est sa qualité
principale sa qualité principale c'est
d'arriver sur un terrain et quels que
soient les joueurs qui sont autour de
lui ses 30 sessions qui se
créent et créer du scoring tu vois c'est
ce qui s'est passé arizona state
et je pense que c'est ce qui va essayer
de faire aussi à houston après c'est pas
des mêmes conditions si on lui demande
mais je moi je ne vois pas jouer
autrement parce qu'on l'a pas vue jouer
autrement à la hac c'est difficile de
s'imaginer qui peut jouer qui peut jouer
porteur de balle créateurs
moi je moi je le vois pas faire ça
parce que je n'ai pas vu parce que je
n'ai pas vu j'ai
waimes après voilà même sur la sur la
bio djala comme je te disais moi il m'a
assez agréablement surpris avec quelques
bonnes passes etc mais ça reste du flash
au mieux au mieux je le vois plus comme
un à eric gordon j'étais moi qui joue
déjà le système ça peut être un bon
objectif pour lui
c'est ça après eric burdon quand ils
arrivent warren billets aux clippers il
était il avait ajouté il était et
christopher il n'arrive pas avec cette
cette réputation de
shooter cure donc c'est pas c'est pas
tout à fait peut-être le même rôle
qu'ont donné mais un rôle de scoring
plus tôt le groupe dit la chair qu'on
soit là voilà
après lycée faire du driver qui tiens
donc
et voilà pourquoi mais comme tu l'as dit
ça au niveau de deux des qualités de
driver des très forts et très puissant
moi je vous invite à regarder ces gens
sont moins impressionnants il ya des
cuisses et des mollets impressionnant le
haut du corps peut encore se développer
il n'est pas il n'ya pas des épaules
surdimensionnées mais le bas du corps
déjà très développé et et puis comme tu
l'as dit au contact n'explose pas
illégal il est assez créatif sur c est
simple que ce qui m'intéresse pour les
gens qui sont capables d'aller au cirque
a quand même des très créatif pour finir
les actions comme cela dit dès 2000 à
73% de finition au cercle ce qui est
fort avec avec seulement 35% dames en 2
passes décisives pour les marques et
dire qu'il y va tout seul et qui est
capable de se frayer des chemins parce
qu'on n'a pas dit c'est que il arrivait
tout juste parce qu'il faut en parler il
arrive de la pac twelve qui nous a
offert à fouquereuil of shame tient
quand même voilà qui met dix ans à dire
c'est une conférence m et comme de la
concurrence car il n'a pas joué tout
seul dans une conférence de lui
bah pour 6 pour citer un petit peu sur
les mecs côté d'europe cette année on
peut quand même parler de evans mobile
et peut parler de crise dure t on peut
parler d'eux d'ailleurs williams donc
quelques jours l'agent la loterie a
confié ne s'obtiennent pialat très bien
porté sur noël assure voyez beaucoup de
mecs en nba encore une fois il ya
thompson aussi qui tent hommes samedi
dans tout et il entouré à tiago
alors non il n'a pas passé le que pur à
100 avec un sol tout est donc
pour moi pelé l'ancien arrière de oregon
state il est plus dans l'effectif après
il joue une place qu'il a joué à sa
place dans ce merdier qui l'a pas été
incroyable mais
après ça voilà c'est un profil qui peut
trouver tu peux trouver une place toute
façon cette conférence voilà moi j'aime
beaucoup et blagues et sud notamment
pour les modes l'oubli mais c'est
quelque chose de très réputé avec des
crocs programme emvol d'arlit on en
parle d'arizona state on parle de répond
que des noms vous retrouver pour que
maintenant dans l'ain sur les bons rails
sur les cinq majeur nba même si c'est
pas des programmes qui sont pas réputés
pour leur organisation de jude law and
done là c'est vrai il va y en avoir
sûrement l'année prochaine
donc louis chiante et sûre peut
peut-être pour sur l'aspect offensif
peut être parce qu'ils sont sous tout
comme tu dis quoi il est souvent
déséquilibré alors ccid on en a parlé
souvent cette année et ceci de me
renseigner la sueur sous tout ça donc en
fait on voit en tout cas ce qu'on voit
quand on voit tout et c'est qu'il pose
en fait ils baissent le ballon sur la
joue gauche 60 droitier
et ils recherchent toujours le s'arrange
gauche si tu veux qu'ils aient cette
habitude qu'il a le fait peu en journée
alors peut-être pas le droit pour
expliquer tout ça quoi mais ça arrange
les usagers non mais c'est simplement
que ça n'aide pas
quand il parle quand il part sur la
droite il faut qu'il ramène le ballon
sur la gauche donc ça augmente la
difficulté il use contorsionner pour
pour arriver à se rééquilibrer c'est ça
qui explique souvent ce ce pied là qui
nous unit tous au pied droit qui partait
en avant pour justement tout chercher
cet équilibre parce que son corps était
tordue mois donc
voilà alors le le fait qu'il ait déjà
qu'on n'ait pas vu ça sur les dessous de
ce qu'il a appris la
[Musique]
pré-saison désir qui bossent dessus est
ce que
ça ne va pas trop avoir le choix va
patrol je puisse vous êtes dans le bourg
d'elster collectif
le projet c'est de développer un maximum
les diables c'est l'ultime attraction
principale pas normal
c'est ce qu'il n'y aura pas énormément
de domaines
sauf s'il est
un peu angélique pour scanner doit
rester après à voter sur le mans qui va
devoir devenir une menace de loin
sachant qu'en plus cette année on va les
avoir
failli des nouvelles règles sur les
gestes qui sont considérés comme non
masqué pour pouvoir pas pour éviter de
pénaliser les défenseurs donc tout ce
qui est pieds en avant s'arrêter se
jeter dans le camp des défenseurs comme
de christopher la bouffe à l'université
sera totalement interdite sera sifflé
faute au point si
jalousement
sur le jeu
les 170 9 heures il a décidé de
rejoindre un programme qui étaient à
bord pour cet avis d'où son frère joué
déjà alors mis à quitter son état mais
on sait que voilà des joueurs là qui est
l'être
je trouve que quelque chose que
tu dis que c'est pas tout le temps vu
comme quelque chose de positif c'est ça
c'est ça on dit des voix que vous l'avez
dit pro james wise men que c'est un
petit peu se
doit vouloir un peu de sécurité à avoir
un peu de mal à se risquer dans
l'inconnu
est ce que moi j'ai pas l'impression est
ce que tu trouves que zeus christopher
c'est quelqu'un qui peut avoir peut-être
du mal à à s'exprimer dans est ce qu'il
ya un peu dans la sécurité est ce que tu
trouves que c'est un mec qui est manque
de confiance en lui moi j'ai
l'impression vu les tirs qui prend qu'il
a fait contre lui
il n'y a pas de s'imposer d'imposer son
jeu quand il a en tout cas il n'a pas
montré du tout cette année à son
instinct et
moi au début de l'année je vous
demandais comment ça allait marcher
parce que c'était toi quand même ces
trois fortes têtes quoi qui ce qui se
télescopaient à l'arrière de l'équipe et
est en fait j'ai regardé les derniers
matches encore une vraie solidarité qui
restait malgré tout ce qui leur est
arrivé de fortis en vidant hyper
décevant par rapport à la projection
composé de l'équipe il ya quand même une
solidarité qui est visible entre
justement les trois 3 arrière
et ça montre comparu il a su s'imposer
et malgré tous ses défauts est rejetée
par les deux des deux seniors qui était
là depuis un moment à
moi je trouve que c'est des bons signaux
j'ai pas trouvé d'autre chose par contre
donc il avait son frère caleb qui jouait
déjà aux manettes il a un frère patrick
qui a joué en pro a aux utah jazz était
exactement il est pas très vitre et
voilà et puis alors il est le héros si
wade une sortie les harkis c'est ça qui
était ce qu'il y avait un beau potentiel
qui était à ses côtés qui a subi une
très grosse blessure t elle sa première
année freshman à l'université qui a mis
fin à sa carrière pour une famille
famille de sportifs eu et puis en tout
cas au niveau des traders voilà et il
est relié par ce frère patrick hivon
à l'attention de tweets donc vous êtes
donc tu vois il s'est quand même le
l'arrière 2-1 didier des deux donc c'est
quand même une famille qui baigne dans
le sport et le basket de plus ou moins
loin et ce genre de choses c'est quand
même positif qu'en france pour une
carrière
c'est alors donc des choses en fait pour
eux parce qu'on ne l'a pas dit je crois
là c'est le parrain de son frère donc
voilà c'est comme ça qu'il a des liens
familiaux et le papa lui musicien mais
voilà qui est très très très fan de
sport et de basket donc oui oui famille
famille de sportifs je regarde sur le
fait qu'ils aient beaucoup équipiers moi
je trouvais aussi jean le terroriste est
le premier à venir relever les mecs à
féliciter et cetera
sachant que pareille à houston je disais
deux gros caractères
auquel
avec lesquels il jouait là dans l'équipe
où il arrive qu une porte en juniors en
cadets de green en termes d'ego et de
caractère un peu fou on se pose là aussi
tout à fait mais et puis là mais c'est
un autre contexte parce qu'elle n'est
pas il est pas mis sur le devant de la
scène
voilà donc il va devoir prouver
moi je t'avoue que c'est assez curieux
de voir comment il va réagir à la
situation et s qui va s'imposer ce qui
va devenir votre compense qui peut
devenir
donc cette espèce de sixième homme
scoreur en sortie de banc fin donc
sixième homme et
ça c'est en garde ça n'intéresse dessus
parce qu'il a vraiment il faut voir que
c'est vraiment un don qui joue un poste
avec des qualités
on recherche des gars comme ça où
il a montré qu'il avait la mentalité
pour vous là il faut qu'il arrive à bien
calés sur le flop et entre 110 kg foot
et puis comme ça et il a des outils pour
défendre on n'a pas parlé beaucoup mais
il est il à cette envergure il a ses
qualités physiques il est comme tu
disais il aime le ballon du coup à
rebondir femme qui est honnête au niveau
universitaire parce qu'il va très haut
et qui n'a pas peur d'aller au contact
et puis au niveau des
des styles il a il aime bien se passer
sur l'une d'eux parce que c'est un truc
qui lie sondages
wen et puis il ya un truc très attirés
vers le ballon ouais c'est ça évidemment
attiré comme un aimant vers le ballon et
ils adorent mettre les mains sur le bas
c'est un truc il adore essayer de chiper
le ballon comme ça en mettant les mains
dans les points derrière le coude il a
vraiment ce réflexe de façon
systématique donc il arrive pas moi je
trouve qu'il arrive pas en étant nulle
en défense april a des soucis sur
picamoles tu m'as parlé et on peut citer
l'article d'emmanuel de névé il a le ce
que tu me report qui est sur le site
d'envergure mais détaille un petit peu
ce qu'ils pensent de lui au niveau du
pick and roll et sa défense ont
donc pour moi ça c'est un défenseur ça
défenseur d'un contenu qui est honnête
après il faut qu'il arrive à défendre au
bol je ne sais pas si comme on dit on
sait pas s'il en est capable j'ai pas vu
n'a pas dû faire
ça va être un peu un autre challenge ou
pas d'ailleurs comme je les aime en
summer league là j'ai vu des press tout
terrain alors c'était de la summer
league donc j'étais en mode la tap a
défendu à mes yeux argunas tu étais là
tu t'y mets donc les outils ça peut être
une norme y va il ya des vétérans à
houston 1 s'intéresse en jeu pour cette
année le times par exemple pour la
lecture du pick and roll s'ils jouent
avec qui est un excellent défenseur
là dessus comme c'est une équipe qui est
assez réputé pour enfin qu'ils entendent
et attendu pour ses qualités de scoring
pour l'instant lé coach essaie de mettre
en place de la défense collective il
insiste beaucoup là dessus donc à voir
dans le développement mais cheval
forcément
inquiet sur sur la défense jusque juin
de voir ces derniers temps là il m'a
montré que sur des missions ils
pouvaient s'y mettre et très très
intriguée par ça parce que si mes la
même intensité en nba ça peut devenir un
prospect vraiment intéressant des deux
côtés du terrain
on lui souhaite d'avoir des minutes pour
vous montrer
ses progrès
moi en tout cas j'ai j'ai hâte j'ai hâte
de suivre ces jeunes là ont
effectivement avoir des minutes avoir
créé des occasions et des digues on
verra de ce qu'il adviendra d'eric
gordon à la trade deadline peut-être que
si houston perd beaucoup qu'on dit à
l'évasion on y va à fond avec les jeunes
ce qui se fera plus rapide opportunités
en tout cas je suis très content d'avoir
fait cet épisode là de rattrapage parce
que c'était quand même un mec très
attendu et on ne va pas suffisamment
parlé l'an prochain alors moi j'ai fais
beaucoup de blagues dessus sur twitter
mais faut rendre à césar ce qui est à
césar c'est un un vrai prospects nba
hyper intrigant et ben merci à toi
d'avoir un compagnon cet épisode puisque
si tu arraches quelque chose à rajouter
dans ce feuilleton feuilleton
wayne je pense qu'on a été pas mal
complet et à écouter merci de nous avoir
aussi écouté jusqu'au bout n'hésitez pas
à commenter n'hésitez pas à partager
n'hésitez pas à nous tenir aussi
informer de les actus de jazz
christopher 6 sur twitter si vous êtes
un fan des des roquettes ça nous on
suivra le petit toute l'année et puis
bah je vais vous demander forcément de
suivre envergure de checker nos contenus
qui sont maintenant le quotidien vous
avez des articles qui l'ont fait tous
les jours 10 coups tirés pendant qu'ils
sont faits tous les jours donc allez-y à
fond et voilà donnez-nous de la force et
au très haut au plus grand monde et nous
on est toujours là pour discuter
prospects avec
on dire au revoir
c'est un peu mon bail dès 18 heures
[Musique]